a tale of two tours that is a subject of
tonight's waters words before Barack
Obama was elected president he flew to
Europe the socialist crowds loved him
and he said this I speak to you not as a
candidate for president but as a citizen
a proud citizen of the United States and
a fellow citizen of the world
you probably remember after his election
he also embarked on the apology tour in
America there's a failure to appreciate
Europe's leading role in the world there
have been times where America's shown
arrogance and been dismissive even
derisively United States is still
working through some of our own darker
periods in our history the United States
will be willing to acknowledge past
errors where those errors have been made
we have at times been disengaged in at
times we've sought to dictate our terms
the media ate this up remember Obama was
the Messiah who'd come down from heaven
to wash away our sins accept Obama's
foreign policy was a disaster the voters
rejected leading from behind enter
Donald Trump here he is in Europe on his
America first tour urging our NATO
allies to pay their bills many countries
are not paying what they should and
frankly many countries o us a tremendous
amount of money folks
many years back we're protecting all of
these countries and then numerous of the
countries go out and make a pipeline
deal with Russia without paying billions
of dollars into the coffers of Russia so
we're supposed to protect you against
Russia but they're paying billions of
dollars
Russia and I think that's very
inappropriate Germany will have almost
70% of their country controlled by
Russia with natural gas on top of that
Germany is just paying a little bit over
1% whereas the United States and actual
members is paying 4.2 percent of a much
larger GDP so I think that's it
appropriate also this has been brought
up by other presidents but other
presidents never did anything about it
because I don't think they understood it
or they just didn't want to get involved
but I have to bring it up because I
think it's very unfair to our country
it's very unfair to our taxpayer first
of all Trump wants Germany buying energy
from America not Russia and that's a
good thing second there's nothing wrong
with asking our allies to pay what
they've promised most of them are
delinquent the media they didn't see it
that way President deploying what you
could call a I know you are but what am
i strategy yeah they call Germany a
captive of Russia yeah is the most
inflammatory language I can imagine the
only beneficiary of trumps havoc is
Vladimir Putin and I don't want to make
light of this but this kind of diplomacy
looks like Hulk smash wait a second I
remember when asking wealthy people to
pay their fair share was good policy
it's only right that we ask everyone to
pay their fair share it was important
for us to make sure that millionaires
and billionaires paid their fair share
making sure the wealthiest Americans
begin to pay their fair share
also Trump is trying to strengthen NATO
and peel Germany away from Russia how
does that help Putin it doesn't the
media is either dumb or it's lying to
you
I also remember Barack Obama actually
alienating our allies and the media is
saying nothing remember he was caught
tapping Angela Merkel's cell phone he
was caught trashing Netanyahu campaigned
against that Israeli prime minister he
left a rack to Isis and Iran he skipped
the Paris peace march and he failed to
back up Ukraine when Russia invaded half
its country the President Trump arrived
in Great Britain holding hands with
Prime Minister Theresa May and after all
the fake news
chaos made this announcement Prime
Minister may and I have just come from a
very productive NATO summit that was
truly a productive summit where my top
priority was getting other NATO members
to pay their full and fair share I'm
pleased to report that we have received
substantial commitments from members to
increase their defence spending and to
do so in a much more timely manner and
so the relationship the special
relationship is stronger than ever
and our NATO allies are pledging to pony
up may be president Trump's tactics are
working